this is huge guys this is everything
read headline on the Bloomberg terminal
right now Obama care subsidies tax
subsidies upheld by the US Supreme Court
that is what everybody's been paying
attention to this case again was not the
prime case that they expected to undo
the Affordable Care Act conservatives
that had problems with it that was in
2012 challenging the constitutionality
of this case this case really came out
of nowhere lower court's ruling on it
making its way to the Supreme Court and
it was literally about four words in
that thousand plus page law stating
whether or not states were the only ones
who could create exchanges to provide
insurance now based on obviously the
very very controversial nature of this
law 34 states declined to create those
exchanges therefore the federal
government was forced to come in and
create exchanges on its own what this
case basically stated was according to
the language written into the law only
States could get subsidies or federal
support for their exchanges therefore
those federal exchanges had they won
this case essentially would have been
moved there would have been six point
five six point six million people that
would have fallen off their insurance
because of the lack of subsidies it
would have created huge problems huge
problems for insurance companies huge
problems for the law and also huge
problems for Republicans on Capitol Hill
that would need to figure out a way to
close that gap all of that is for naught
according to the headlines that just
cross from our own greg stohr the tax
subsidies were upheld basically what
they're saying is the supreme court went
with the intent of the law not the
specific language will be really
interesting to read this opinion but
guys this was the latest and really
biggest threat to the Obamacare the
Affordable Care Act probably the last
one for this administration this cements
the president's cornerstone achievement
for his legacy for his two terms in
office it will stand